okay guys my name is just McDonald today
it's the 19th of March and you're tuned
into gamespot news if you've been
patiently waiting some more information
on star wars battlefront then today is
totally your day because that's exactly
what I have for you well almost EA have
confirmed that they will be dropping a
bunch of battlefront details during an
event next month which is literally
called the Star Wars Celebration the
event takes place from April 16 to 19 in
anaheim california they also mentioned
that the game will only be coming to pc
ps4 and xbox one when it releases this
holiday season alongside the upcoming
Star Wars film The Force awakens it's
another day of dispelling rumors and
internet gossip so here's what will and
won't be happening with gears of war
early this week gamers were pretty
excited about a rumored Marcus Fenix
collection which would supposedly bundle
up HD remasters over the first three
gears of war games for xbox one today
black tusk producer rod fergusson has
set the record straight tweeting I love
the passion but there's no Marcus Fenix
collection we are working on other
exciting gears projects i'll see you at
e3 so no remastered gears collection for
us then but it sounds like things are on
the way probably including the new gears
game being developed for Xbox one by
black task and finally it's drama
abounds today with the news that there
may have been a massive falling out
between Hideo Kojima and publisher
Konami an inside sources told GameSpot
that senior staff at kojima productions
are having their access to corporate
internet emails and phones restricted
apparently key dads like kajima will
also now have limited opportunities to
lend their appearance to promotions of
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain as a
result of power struggles senior staff
at the studio including kajima are now
essentially employed as contractors and
not
permanent employees our source within
Konami also suggested that once the
phantom pain is wrapped there's a good
chance kajima and upper management will
leave Konami since their contract ends
in December Konami have begun removing
the kajima productions logo from all
official Metal Gear art and kojima is no
longer on their executive team when
approached for comment Konami said they
would not discuss the specifics but
offered the statement konami digital
entertainment including mr. Kojima will
continue to develop and support Metal
Gear products please look forward to
future announcements let me know down in
the comments what you think of this
kajima Konami power struggle you can add
against bots or we've got news on
Microsoft's Xbox 360 legal drama and
evolves brand new content those are all
the good things that I wanted to tell
you that today do a little tomorrow i
have my top five stories out the whole
gaming week i hope to see them